thank you finally somebody has come to
stand out to Big conservatives VidCon
and the hero is here
Steven Crowder
is now using our talking points from
2016.
the time has come
okay so Stephen Crowder
apparently was trying to leave YouTube
which don't blame him
um and he was I guess looking for
different offers and now he's not gonna
say by the way it's not the blaze
because he explicitly says it's not the
blaze
but it's a daily wire but
um everyone's saying it's it's a daily
wire because I still don't I still yeah
you know what's funny nobody is getting
giving me a convincing argument as to
why it's the daily wire until Royce came
up with his today and I was like oh okay
every new like rebart and the Blaze and
all of these mini and big bigger
conservative like you know either
podcasting sites or news things or
whatever have written a story about this
Crowder thing except for the daily wire
unless I've missed it but I looked
that's strange that's weird right like
everybody would so
Crowder
is here to fight like hell
um now exists
to begin with um
it's been a while I want you to I want
you to keep your eyes peeled race for
how [ __ ] jacked up on Adderall he is
okay
either this
has to stop
or
I'm going to have to stop
here we go Griff number we've been
covering them since the beginning pretty
much and this how many times has he
threaten to quit once a year right this
yeah this is this is Griff number five
oh how many years do we have to show
that's how many years it's happened but
he does it annually and it's right
either it's right always right at the
end of the year or at the beginning of
the year well it's usually right after
he comes back with a little vacation
from Christmas because he took a hit for
taking a month off will now remember two
of the I'm going away were during
Christmas yeah yeah good point and it
was like Willie or will he and he knew
he was coming back you know either this
one he does this once a year
I'm about to discuss has to stop
or I don't know this uh
this may just not be for me anymore so
doing that I'm gonna take my ball and go
and you're not going anywhere Steve your
dad won't let you but your boss won't
let you whatever
same guy this is not for me anymore he's
done this guys he's done this a million
times all day every year he don't fall
for this guys don't fall for this the
what what I today the reason when I saw
much of this video
what I said was like so wait a second
now Crowder
is saying the things about like daily
wire for example that we were saying
about him when he was doing the same
thing right and but when we did that his
fan said that we were haters and that we
were jealous and now Crowder is
basically saying the exact same thing
they were right and I was in on it for a
while right the difference between us
Crowder is that we were never in on it
okay
we've always been our own we've always
put Joker burning the money it's more
fun yeah
it's a month later but it's more fun
because of the look on your dumb faces
every time we do it
that get you meaning the Crowders not
the audience
but the dumb look on their faces
whenever they're alive I can't believe
they're doing this why are they trying
to destroy the conservative right
because you're all [ __ ] gatekeeping
lying [ __ ] that's why
let me explain give me a few minutes of
your time because contact 27 minutes
text matters here I ask that you don't
skip ahead
buddy because I let me keep that
engagement up let me explain something
to you there is no way I'm going 27
minutes into a crowded video without
skipping ahead a little bit won't take
very long
27 minutes this has been a long time I'm
as likely to last 27 minutes in this
video as I would last 27 minutes with
your wife yeah this is a conversation
that I've actively avoided sidestepped
um and I've hoped why why haven't you
actively avoided and sidestepped this
there's such great deception going on
and these people are out [ __ ]
everybody and gay why would you go to
such great lengths and if it's and if
it's still that bad right and if it's
still that bad right
why aren't you naming names because
that's what bothered me what bothered me
is that he says it here in a second he
goes I'm not going to name names so
you're going to sit there you're going
to [ __ ] on probably rightfully so I'm
sure they [ __ ] him oh yeah the
contract's gross and the people he's
dealing with are gross but when he holds
a contract up and goes I don't want to
have to name names I want you guys to
come correct this is all a negotiation
tactic well specially it's all just
extortion and speculation also pushes
the algorithm because you have more
people tweeting trying to guess who it
is
it's it's it's all an algorithm game I
mean look you can say what you want but
they but one of the one of the key one
of the kings of the algorithm game is is
Tim Poole right like he'll be the first
one to admit it he's he's one of the
kings of the [ __ ] algorithm game can
I can I tell you why I disagree with you
though okay if he was playing an
algorithm game it would end with him
eventually revealing who it is he's
never gonna tell us
right because I think he says in this
video you're here in a little in a
second here like this is a negotiation
he's literally holding the contract up
at some point and going don't make me do
this don't make me do this we could all
go to the go about this the right way
it's a mafia attack it's literally like
Hey listen why don't we all be we could
all be gentlemen about this nobody has
to get hurt it's kind of it's kind of
like in the middle of like when Marvel
was really blowing up and they didn't
offer Samuel L Jackson enough money so
he had his press agent releasing well
Dan Samuel Jackson unfortunately is not
going to be playing Nick Fury anymore
and they're like
and then of course they gave them all
they gave him all the money he wanted in
a Disney Plus show to boot just to make
sure he'd stay so it's the same thing
and Howard Stern is the king of this
here's another one that the king of this
is Howard Stern how many times did
Howard Stern go I might go to podcasting
I might not resign with Sirius he always
did that and he always resigned so yeah
and then Opie would do the same thing
except nobody cared yeah
still [ __ ] about that to this day
five-year deal they were offered us take
the [ __ ]
so I don't understand
why I know why he does this but again
the thing is that we've always gotten
[ __ ] for this you know and sometimes
rightfully so and sometimes we've been
right
but we've always gotten [ __ ] for calling
these people out and then everyone's
saying like oh you don't pass it
everyone has to pass a purity test and
this and that's the problem is with
people like us when we assume most of
these people are [ __ ] ninety percent
of the time we're right and that's just
how it's been going right uh
conservative Inc is exactly what big by
the way Khan a big con it's time to stop
big con okay [ __ ] off because you were
part of that so now he's still part of
it no no no no I know just yeah this is
all just a he didn't like his cut but
here's what happened with Crowder
Crowder is now going to say he's going
to start his own streaming Network
Crowder you already had your own
streaming Network you had CR TV that was
yours and what you did was you gave up
that freedom to go sign with a big
conglomerate now that big conglomerate
that big conglomerate is told you you
got to leave now you're trying to go to
another one and they're not giving you
the deal you think you deserve now
here's the way it goes though if you
don't like this is this is all selfish
and self-serving and I think that's the
problem with Crowder and that's why he
loses a lot of people this isn't because
he's trying to fix the conservative
movement or get somebody elected this is
because somebody [ __ ] him personally
this is because somebody [ __ ] him
personally and not even personally but
Prophet like he doesn't like his cut
yeah it's all it comes down to we did a
heist you told me I was getting a
certain cut this was not my cut and now
I'm gonna burn I'm gonna start naming
names he's never gonna name me and now
what I hate about this is fine he's
extorting whoever the daily wire or
whoever it is I said on nightwave last
night I I one of the only things I agree
with Nick Fuentes on is that crime is
based extortion is based if you can get
away with it it's based so if he's
trying to extort the daily wire or
whoever it is that's totally based in my
opinion what I don't like is that you're
trying to extort them but in the same
breath and in the same video try to
present yourself like the big reveal is
coming like I'm gonna name names or oh
you know and he's never going to protect
the people he's claiming on video to be
protecting like I'm doing this for you
that's the part I don't like if he just
went on here held up the contract and
was like you want me to start naming
names huh you want me to start uh
telling everybody how you [ __ ] do
business it behind the scenes little rat
[ __ ] and didn't go guys I'm fighting for
you go to stop bigcon.com right just
pick one if he was just
like like vague like throwing Veil
threats and holding up the contract and
being like maybe I got the unredacted
version maybe we play that [ __ ] game
then I'd actually have some respect for
Crowder I'd be like oh snap my man is
extorting these [ __ ] good for him but
he's trying to be two things at once and
some of these dumb boomers are gonna eat
it up you can't be stop vidcon.com but
then next week have Jordan Peterson on
because he's part of that that's the
issue big con to see the difference is
is that for Martian is a great example
we have a big umbrella of people that
fall into that big conservative movement
it's more it's more people than there is
less people right
when it comes to Crowder big condo crowd
are only the people that aren't nice to
him he'll still have [ __ ] Charlie
Kirk on who's part of a VidCon he'll
still have every other daily he also
have Matt Walsh on who's part of daily
wires because he'll still have him on he
doesn't [ __ ] care he's not fighting
big con he's just you know what he's mad
about he's mad that he didn't get except
look if all of these people that have
been doing this for other people would
have paid him the percentage he wanted
it he would be sitting there right now
being part of big con like everybody
else the difference is he didn't get his
[ __ ] cut so he took out his Underwood
[ __ ] typewriter and typed up a letter
is what he did he's doing this is
exactly from [ __ ] house of cards
right he typed up a letter
yeah he's Mori from Goodfellas exactly
well Jimmy I want my [ __ ] buddy what
do I look like a [ __ ] schmuck on
Wheels yeah I could have dropped the
dime a hundred times
and this is what he's doing others wigs
never come off
near the Crowders that's what I said I
said Crowder's way oh I'm sorry I broke
I apologize assume sometimes farts yeah
okay
be necessary that you said Murray's wigs
very behind the scenes for a long while
but that's no longer possible so why if
you've watched for the last decade
you know that I've always made it clear
that we here at mug Club are in the
business of giving you the business and
let me tell you business is Boom
business is booming serving you
the viewer you watching listening right
now I've also made it clear that I
wouldn't be in the business of attacking
other conservatives uh regardless
of disagreements or personal issues and
but here you are attacking another just
because you're not naming their names
doesn't mean you're not attacking other
conservatives because now you are see
the difference is we've always been open
to attacking other conservatives because
some of you are phony and what Marsha
and I have been saying for years was no
[ __ ] quality control with you people
there's zero there's none you let all
these [ __ ] hucksters come in before
you know you have Tom McDonald's coming
into the world who by the way told
Rolling Stones at Kyle Rittenhouse we
shouldn't be we shouldn't be uplifting
Kyle Rittenhouse for [ __ ] defending
himself that other [ __ ] phony and
then we have a bunch of Canadians
flooding to America trying to tell me
what the Bill of Rights is go [ __ ]
yourself you and the [ __ ] most you
ruined in on I'm [ __ ] so sick of this
so sick of this
I've always explained my logic was
relatively simple I believe that the
world was better with more voices out
there rather than less regardless of
minute differences considering the
magnitude of uh Stephen that's
irregardless yeah Stephen
um read a book
have you not gotten Lex Friedman's for a
summer reading list
at all that we are genuinely fighting
for our country right now
but no we're not we lost a long time ago
the difference is merch and I were just
ahead of the curve that's all we knew we
lost a long time ago
for the first time I have to say
that I believe many of those in charge
in the right-leaning media
are actually at odds with what's best
for you
the viewer sounds like he's gonna the
customer and more importantly the
country
congratulations welcome to what we were
saying six years ago wow Bud real Brave
real Crowder was real Brave a bunch of
once a bunch of people started doing
this then he was like you know what my
turn
all right it's I'm gonna go out I'm
counter counter Counter Culture I'll
have you know I I despise this man this
is so phony and by the way customers he
called them customers shut up
we here at my club we thought that we
were all in this together that we were
fighting the the media well except for
not gay charity you may send an NDA
except for that yeah and you're like wow
we all here at mudflug you know 10 years
ago we all thought nobody's there from
10 years ago except your dad
it's nobody left you know what I've
noticed immersion this is something I
guess we never really nobody there from
five years ago you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
don't have any friends Everybody Plays
all these little games and and it's like
since all these little conservative
people are all kind of intertwined like
everybody does a show with somebody
who's on another show who's on through
the show you know what I'm saying like
it's it's this long thing
when you let guys like us that have been
going after these people you've seen at
Marsh we've seen this happen to both of
us you know you get a little ostracized
when you meet new people right because
you'll always be like oh yeah those are
the guys that talk [ __ ] about Crowder yo
those the guys talking about oh those
are guys and and it's all and you can
tell that a lot of these people even
agree with us but nobody wants to
[ __ ] say anything because everybody
wants to keep their little [ __ ]
options open and everybody wants to be
able to always be like I don't care
about that man I want to do my show and
honestly merch and I rarely even like
having guests on there's a couple people
we [ __ ] love having on and don't get
me wrong they're great for the most part
Merchant I to quote JJ we just won't do
our show man and that's pretty much it
for us I don't want to have to pay 500
3D chess with some of these [ __ ]
[ __ ] I just it's boring it's
annoying for what for them to turn on
each other every two seconds that's all
that happens it's fun watching the crack
show though because it's like you know
it's like the thing I've been saying
forever it's like I knew you guys never
liked each other I mean you guys ever
liked each other and now it's all coming
to the surface that you never liked each
other this was all make believe you were
one of the Gatekeepers too
yeah we always said that like in the
early days like when when friends of
ours and like Marsh was losing his
Twitter account and all that like
Crowder wasn't one of those dudes that
was fighting for other people to get
their accounts back he wasn't as putting
his neck out there for other channels
I don't
do you remember because what I remember
is because Crowder decided to have a
little spat with Carla what was his name
Carlos Mazza somebody who's disappeared
Carlos Mazza that Vox adpocalypse
happened to stuff that would go away huh
yeah stuff that yeah his parents are
rich he doesn't even work uh stuff that
we the same with Crowder I guess
um the
um what was I saying oh
um we we got demonetized and we're still
dealing with that today because we got
demonetized three years ago in July they
demonetized our clip Channel which was
perfectly clean because it was attached
to it because every fight that Crowder
had represented everybody else and we
all [ __ ] paid and look I'm not saying
that we would be Crowder is the only
reason we got demonetized I'm sure we
would have been demonetized no matter
what but my whole point is is that
Crowder what you you were at a point the
head of this movement weren't you you
were the guy and the truth is and I
think anybody who's paying attention
were to go people aren't talking about
crowded like they used to am I wrong
used to be like you would see his change
my Minds would literally pop up in your
algorithms like all the time on Facebook
on Twitter on everything and now not as
much you notice that dude it's like the
Ben Shapiro debates you used to see him
everywhere like it destroys owns people
were like pushing it everywhere now you
don't that everyone hates him I think he
also just doesn't go anywhere anymore
like he just does a show in his Studio
it's easier yeah
big Tech is in bed with big con
we know we know holy [ __ ] are you late
to the game
what's
are you joking Stephen are you [ __ ]
serious right now are you joking right
now
how has anybody take this guy seriously
I tweeted out a joke tweet from this
video and I was like he needs to do
three things to redeem himself number
one name names number two higher back
knock a Jared and number three and I
said and most importantly and I put it
in all caps stop doing cringe parody
songs I had a bunch of people replying
well I agree with one and two but I
actually like his parody I was like oh
my God and it was all the people that
said they like this parody songs had
names like Maga grandma and stuff like
that and like oh that makes sense
it's Thunderstruck except it's about
Obama oh God Patriot Patriot trucker 48
exactly
the people you thought
the people I thought were fighting for
you
a lot of it has been
a big con we know you're you're part of
it he was you were in on it and you just
don't like you cut now buddy that's all
this is holy [ __ ] that's exactly it's
the only way to phrase this you were in
on it and you just didn't like the
amount of money you had I know we
haven't watched the entire thing yet but
if halfway through it he goes and also
I'd like to tell you guys the story
called The Machine oh no you better not
he better not we ain't even gonna get
halfway through this thing it's a long
last video two minutes
so bad we've gotten two minutes in
now I'm specifically avoiding naming
names or going at Ben Shapiro daily wire
you specifically avoiding naming names
or going after people because that would
have consequences don't worry one of the
top comments is from Tim Poole Crowder
is right about everything
ah I hate these people
after individuals keep kissing ass is
the only way you make it
uh in this video
because I genuinely hope that those I'm
addressing and you know who you are Ben
Shapiro
daily wire have a change of heart
it's it's never too late to do the right
thing
guys
this is a genuine plate we can all do
better
we can is he doing the speech at the end
of the [ __ ] Captain America Winter
Soldier one I'm do better oh he's what
do you Anthony Mackey [ __ ] if I could
change oh my God you've changed
oh my God
and all do better it doesn't have to be
this way and Oh no you're out of order
this whole Court waiter with Stephen
you're breaking my heart Anakin
that's when Star Wars
don't say hello to my little friend
let me have to provide receipts
no he's got to provide receipts
do the others out there
um who have now been able to verify
have been locked into exploitative
contracts that I have I just want to
point out I was looking this up because
obviously like I wanted to learn a
little more about it and Royce said
daily wire a few other people think it's
daily wire for another reason uh if you
look at this he's gonna show like
redacted screenshots if you look at the
length of what's redacted it seems like
only something that long would be okay
daily Wire yeah it's the internet but
people will figure that out yeah but it
is but but locked into exploitive
contracts but but look I am not
defending daily wire I think they're
evil and I mean that we've said that I
think they're [ __ ] evil
that being said
that being said and I don't think
everybody that works here is evil
because that's not fair but I think that
as in all of them every single one as an
organization even the UPS guy that drops
off the mail there mm-hmm
yeah
um
I think I I but but I I just daily wires
under no obligation to give you the deal
that you want Crowder that's how
business works you know that right you
should see this contract though it's
wild oh no no no no no no no I haven't
seen the I haven't read like read it
I've heard his explanation why does he
yeah here it is here it is here is here
I got it
here you go it was made very clear to me
in no uncertain terms this is what's
sent out to everybody
is it something crazy like you do the
work but don't get paid till a month
later
a month God that'd be sweet
and then if you get then if you get a
strike meaning the suspension was real
[ __ ] awkward yeah I felt
uncomfortable
as a reminder YouTube still owes us like
five thousand dollars nobody's ever
forgotten that YouTube I sometimes wake
up thinking about that you owe me five
thousand dollars and if you're gonna
then if you get a strike
meaning of suspension another 20 percent
okay so wait uh all right so okay
reduction of fee from Lost revenue from
boycotts content strikes or bans for
major social media platforms a ad drop
if Crowder is boycotted or dropped by
more than 50 percent of of his then ex
extent advertised partners that is 50 of
revenue from those partners and the
company is not able to replace them
within 90 days then the fee will be
reduced by 25 until such time the ad
Revenue has been restored so if Crowder
gets boycotted for doing his show for
let's not use Crowder because I don't
because it's I don't want to defend
credit yeah yeah yeah let's do this if
employee let's just use employee because
I agree with you this is insane if an
employee of the daily wire I'm going to
say the daily wire if I'm wrong whatever
I don't care [ __ ] off I'm going to say
I'm assuming this is the daily wire
if they get boycotted which by the way
is something you can't control right
like you cannot control that there's no
way to know what the next thing that
people are going to boycott about right
and they lose their sponsor and then
remember when it was Goya beans yes
and they in 90 days
cannot replace it
you lose money now B content strike
something that if you've been on YouTube
by the way
you know you can't control this okay we
got a strike for bullying a dead Jeffrey
Epstein yeah you'll get them for such
arbitrary reasons and lose an appeal
that you can't predict this now the
reason this is kind of so
the reason this is relevant is because
whoever wrote this contract is doing one
of those deals like a lot of these
people are doing where they're basically
buying your YouTube channel yes and
keeping everything
so that's why they're like oh well if
you [ __ ] up the channel then you know
that hurts it for us so it's like it's
this whole this whole
like business model is weird to me
because I wouldn't want to buy anybody's
YouTube channel anyway and like have
them run it because I wouldn't want to
be out that money so this is just a dumb
contract idea in the first place well
the last one is nuts because I skipped
over content straight because that's the
same thing if you get a Content strike
uh 25 you lose 25 of your income right
but the band this one's nuts if Crowder
content cannot be released on any of the
major platforms YouTube Facebook Apple
podcast Spotify because if Crowder's
content being banned from these
platforms and the fee will be reduced by
one YouTube twenty percent Apple podcast
20 Facebook 10 spot of again that's not
something you could control
yeah especially when these guys can call
each other and wipe somebody out like
Alex Jones in a day
so basically here's what really happened
Crowder had this contract given to him
Crowder said I'm not going to sign it
unless you remove Amendment 13 is what
it seems to be right I don't know that
no this isn't even the worst of them no
no no no I I know I'm sorry you're
misunderstanding me I'm gonna I'm gonna
keep going I'm just saying well you see
the penalty Clauses missing shows I
wasn't being specific to this one I was
just giving you oh yeah no no Crowder
basically said if you don't remove all
these elements that I don't like from
the contract right then I'm not signing
and they said well we're not removing it
goes if you don't remove it I'm going to
tell people you're doing this
is basically where we're at right now in
this process now and now he's hinting
he's going to do it so that they come to
him quietly and give him what he wants
uh it's it's very quick that he shows it
on screen you got to go back it's close
to this it's it's close to this but when
you see up up I saw some white there
that's where we're at already oh okay
and then there's a little bit more that
he shows very briefly
um
God where is he I can pull it up I can
play it's fine I'll find it it's not a
big deal
basically I can break it down it's if
you miss a [ __ ] Daily Show
you are out something like 10 grand and
then if you if you miss like a monthly
special show it's like [ __ ] 50 Grand
and it was like a million dollars if you
miss an annual thing it was weird dude
it was like 8 19. all these all these
crazy stipulations if you [ __ ] don't
um thank you thank you Patsy okay here
we go okay oh these are more stuff oh no
that's the merch that's the merchant two
is the fee reduction okay I'm gonna do
52 but hold on let me look at I wanna I
I haven't seen the merch thing
will maintain the exclusive ride to
create and sell Crowder and Crowder
content brand merchandise all
remediation of the whatever the shark
okay whatever fine email list social
media will have the exclusive right to
manage
so the daily wire will probably have the
right to manage a curate monetize
Crowder's official Facebook wow they
take everything over
so what also can I say it might be
here's another reason I think it's daily
wires we shorten it they shorten it to
DW
right that's what I'm thinking too
so fee reductions okay daily content if
Crowder fails for any reason to deliver
192 episodes
he only has to do 192 episodes you guys
don't please don't get don't get mad
don't get merch
he only has to do how many hey don't get
mad at me I was the one that wanted to
start taking Mondays off that's good
that wouldn't even put a dent in that
though that's true but we'd be slightly
less angry
okay that must be nice
if Crowder fails for any reason to
deliver 192 episodes of The Daily Show
including any and all add reads and
promo reads approved for deem
satisfactory of the company hundred
thousand dollars so monthly 250 1
million for the annual characters of
annual content in any year including any
of the and all reads and promo reads
approved and deemed satisfactory by the
company a million oh my God
this has to be Benny boy right yeah I
mean one of his one of his people
no but I mean
it's his company it's just uh and if you
don't do this you have me a million
dollars
yeah that's what I was doing
why because it's designed for you it's
not designed for the sponsors
if it's four five six seven sponsors
sponsors they're no longer the product
you're the product well 80 and 90
sponsors gross too many sponsors you do
like sponsors Stephen
so we've adapted here
I don't need this we've been demonetized
and we're not beholden
to sponsors who might get boycotted
because the sponsors that we have are
going to go wherever we go anyway we
know that Beyond any shadow of a doubt
that's the luxury of doing business
honestly
right and loyalty and ndas
but to the kids out there coming up who
don't have that luxury
please don't sign these
Crowder
do not pretend like you care about the
kids coming up no he does bro his heart
is like going out to them to not [ __ ]
pretend
because you don't
you care about Crowder Inc which is just
a smaller subset of conservative ink
which is if you go to stop bigcon.com it
literally is just sign up for mug Club I
swear to God
he does this all the time go to stop
VidCon
go to stop bigcon.com live on the air
right now shout out to Davey Crocker who
just told me about this
stop bigcon.com and get ready for it
guys
that's
all it is
that's how we're gonna stop VidCon folks
he's not even trying anymore
he's not even trying anymore he's not
even hiding it you know what I mean